Các bạn khi tôi nhìn đình với các số liệu dự báo hiện này,
xíu báo đu phía in chưa có khả năng dí chuyển và bình đông.
Tuy nhiên, giò cứng đô rất mạnh,
khoan liệu của báo có thể làm ra tăng trường gió trên khu bực biến đông trong những ngày tới,
từ nay đến khoảng ngày 1.3,
xíu báo đu phía in được dự báo,
chưa gây tạo động trực tiếp đến bình đông,
tuy nhiên từ khoảng 1.3,
khi báo tiến gần khu bực biệt mắt đảo này,
quan Trung Quốc, khoan liệu báo có thể làm gió tay năng trên khu bực biến đông,
mạnh đông mạnh lên, giữa báo cho các ngày 6.3,
giò tay năng trên nhiều khu bực bắt, giữa và năng biệt đông,
bao gồm buộc biệt hoàn xa và trường xa,
có thể mạnh đấp 6 đến mạnh,
xong biển cao hai đến bột mẽ, gây biển đông mạnh.
Trong tâm dự báo khi tự thuy bản của gia cho biết,
đang tiếp tục theo giỏi xa dịch biển của xíu báo đu phía
và sẽ cập nhật các thùng tiến mời nhất về khả năng tắc đất của báo.